[Music]
January is the start of a new year and
it also kicks off a bunch of big video
game news this month was packed with
game announcements crazy mods and a few
sad goodbyes you're here to see the best
of it so let's get to it these are the
top 10 stories of January number 10 the
Apocalypse Now video game I love the
smell of Kickstarter in the morning and
that's why I have to bring up this very
unexpected announcement legendary
director Francis Ford Coppola is teaming
up with the games industry to make a
video game adaptation of Apocalypse Now
what's more it's going to be a survival
horror RPG just let that sink in for a
second the project is in its very early
days but we could be only a few short
years away from taking down Colonel
Kurtz ourselves number 9 GTA 4 in GTA 5
speaking of the classics let's talk
about grand theft auto if GTA 5 los
santos just wasn't big enough for you
then why not add GTA fours Liberty City
to the map that's exactly what mod team
opened for is working on you will have
to own both games on PC but doing so
will drop Liberty City right across the
sea from Los Santos open for aims to
release the mod this spring number 8
Resident Evil in first person open for
aren't the only modders out there making
cool stuff in celebration of Resident
Evil sevens release mater rod Lima is
working on his own first-person
experience
he took assets from Resident Evil remake
and Umbrella Chronicles to build his own
first-person demo in the Unreal Engine
there's currently no word on whether
this will ever be a playable thing since
rod has plenty of scripting and
animation to tweak in the meantime you
can get your zombie fix from reviving
Resident Evil our GS Studios documentary
on the series re-emergence number 7 Dark
Souls threes final expansion the Dark
Souls saga is finally coming to a close
and here to take us out is the final
expansion the rain city this DLC will
pack in the usual new bosses web
armor and magic but the crazy part is in
the official description which says this
expansion is set quote at the close of
the age of fire as the world ends and
all lands converge upon themselves if
you follow the Dark Souls lore you know
exactly why that's so significant in any
case the ring city will be out on all
platforms on March 28th number 6 Square
Enix is Avengers project Dark Souls may
be ending but another series is just
beginning
Square Enix has announced a partnership
with Marvel to develop Avengers games
the first of which is coming from the
tomb raider team at Crystal Dynamics and
the Deus Ex team at idose Montreal it'll
be a completely original story featuring
everyone's favorite box office
superheroes all we've seen so far is a
little teaser trailer but this is going
to be an ongoing project with multiple
titles and III seems like a good place
to keep an eye out
number 5 Xbox one changes Microsoft is
always experimenting with the Xbox one
experience but there are some big
changes coming soon we just got a look
at the new home screen which simplifies
the whole layout it makes it easier to
access things like recent games and
video clips the update also removes Xbox
ones snap feature
according to engineering lead Mike
Ibarra this was done to quote improve
multitasking reduce memory use improve
overall speed and free up resources
going forward for bigger things the
changes will be live for everyone
sometime this spring and then you'll
have to actually play games instead of
binge watching house of cards in the
corner number 4 Mass Effect and drama
does release date we're only a few
months out from Andromeda which was
finally confirmed to launch on March
21st in North America March 23rd in
Europe
Bioware had plenty more information to
share since the announcement like HDR
support a 10 hour trial for EA and
origin access members and no season pass
we've also seen a bunch of new trailers
which have shown off the new tempest
ship and a few of our future squad mates
will be able to launch very soon
Pathfinder number three the
hello Mega Bloks game speaking of space
games did you know there was a halo Mega
Bloks game in the works it was cancelled
after only ten months of development but
footage of the prototype has been
released to the public for us to see
what could have been it was planned to
be a Halo game for a younger audience
which seems like a no-brainer given the
popularity of the franchise but I guess
your kids can always play with the halo
Mega Bloks toy sets instead number two
scalebound cancelled halo Mega Bloks
wasn't the only cancellation of the
month or they only canceled Xbox game
for that matter after a day full of
rumours Microsoft revealed that
PlatinumGames scalebound had been axed
we don't know why the project was canned
but director Hideki Kamiya was quick to
apologize for the situation and deny
that he was taking any time off for
mental health reasons it's a shame we
won't get to fight a bunch of dragons on
our Xbox ones this year but there are
plenty of other games in the works for
2017 number one all the Nintendo switch
details and now it's time to talk about
Nintendo there's almost too much to fit
onto this list but I'm gonna try here
goes
the switch costs $300 and it comes out
on March 3rd launch games include zelda
breath of the wild one to switch
Skylanders imagine aters I am setsuna
and super Bomberman are Mario Kart 8 lux
splatoon to Arms and Super Mario Odyssey
are all planned for this year as well
pro controllers are shelling out all
over the place so hopefully you've been
able to grab one there are tons more
game announcements and release dates out
there so hop over to GameSpot for even
more I need a breather so those were the
biggest news stories of January seems
like a pretty good start to 2017 and if
you want to keep up with everything else
going on this year make sure you hit
that subscribe button in the meantime
you can stay tuned to game spot for all
the coolest videos features and reviews
you